et maintenant je pars fous Sport elle
est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
je
suis resté pour toi
je suis un peu il faut que je regarde ce
que j'ai un coup de fil à Sofinco crédit
et je leur ai dit non non mais moi je
rembourse pas
donc ça va pour a priori ça c'est bon en
fait
alors actualités alors Nice encore une
attaque terroriste
enfin je sais pas c'est quand tu penses
que ça aurait pu être évité si seulement
avant de faire sa connerie le mec il
s'était connecter au site stop
djihadisme
donc à Nice 3 militaires sont agressés à
l'arme blanche alors je vous rassure
avec des rien
alors tu vas me dire ils étaient armés
pourquoi ils n'ont pas de tirer il faut
savoir que cette année il y a eu un
problème avec les flingues aux dernières
nouvelles JouéClub résolu problème
parce que ça a travaillé donc
après faut comprendre à Coulibaly parce
que l'agresseur s'appelle Coulibaly
il y avait une chance sur 1 million
c'est sur les
le mec il aura vraiment mourir dans un
magasin alors qu'il avait le sens de la
vie
bref les soldats ont été décorés parce
qu'ils ont réussi à maîtriser le mec
sans faire usage de leurs armes
ouais
les mecs qui passent leur journée à se
faire chier avec des fusils qui pèse 5
kg et on les décors parce qu'ils
arrivent à s'en servir comme matraque
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude on a décortiqué le
profil de l'agresseur et c'est toujours
le même profil une fois de plus il est
poli il est gentil il est à l'écoute
c'est quand même dingue
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours nouvelles élections
partielles FN contre PS deuxième tour
première victime c'est Nicolas
c'est alors maintenant ça tombe sur lui
c'est c'est le Coulibaly de la politique
Sarkozy Sarkozy Sarkozy Sarkozy
conférencier
et
moi j'ai l'impression de voir
et tu lui dis
n'importe quoi
à 2 ans de l'échéance il a il a perdu
il réussi à perdre Stalingrad avant que
la guerre a commencé
et quand il faut
que je
change de rôle
bon Nicolas moi je sais ce qui se passe
en ce moment en toi je le sens pas de
geste brusque je respecte ta colère tu
sais depuis ton retour il avait sorti
qui avait un décalage entre ce que tu
racontes est-ce que tu sens ça se voit
tout de suite que la synthèse c'est pas
ton truc même ton corps il est pas prévu
pour ça donc ton corps il était il est
prévu pour découper des des des petites
bavette d'aloyau mais pas pour malaxer
de la pâte à crêpes tu vois tu es un mec
tu étais comme ça quoi tu es pas fait
pour ça et est-ce que je t'aime très
fort en toi mais très fort c'est que au
fond de toi tu as besoin de meurtre mais
il faut le faire concrètement et de
manière légal parce que débarqué avec
une Kalash ton conseil du MP c'est quoi
ciment impossible à réaliser
moi
moi je veux bien t'aider faut y aller un
parrain en choisissant Cécile Morano
c'est pas compliqué Nadine Morano tu
t'en débarrasse pas si tu prends une
grenade tu achètes et je lui ai dit va
chercher
Xavier Bertrand
Xavier Bertrand faut y aller au VI à la
subtilité tous les jours tu fais livrer
5 kg de chouquettes pur beurre
dans un mois c'est Bison Futé dans ses
artères c'est bon
Bruno Le Maire c'est le mec pose et tout
tu sens que c'est un coin c'est qui est
fasciné par les lumières pour le
bombardier d'inviter je te parie
commande trois mois avant le trouver au
Carlton de Lille à sans fil et de la
chtouille avec Lolita
[Applaudissements]
alors tu vas me dire et Juppé que je
fait Juppé Juppé je te dis tout de suite
faut pas le ménage et il faut le
déménager
il aura 72 ans en 2017 je te dis ça je
t'ai rien dit
tu fais juste un truc à l'UMP tu baisse
le thermostat il est avant tu m'as 19 le
mec qui sont rhume c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
le pauvre comme si ça suffisait pas au
même moment Valls est passé devant lui
dans les sondages 2e tour présidentielle
ce qui m'a inspiré un petit poème poème
le soir tombait la législative partielle
étaient bien noirs il avait pourtant
l'offensive est presque la victoire il
tenait François acculé sur son pédalo
malgré ses tickets c'est conférence sur
le dos et supporter péniblement le temps
long d'avant 2017 faisan dans la
synthèse improbable la triste c'est net
languissant d'être coincé entre deux
amants que tout oppose la gauche au
point le FN à la rose ils étaient les
sondages qui lui donnerai des ailes avec
des d'espoir il s'écrit à Nicolas c'est
Emmanuel
pour finir
sur une note positive
encourageante dèche a brûlé le pilote
jordanien c'est encourageant bah oui on
progresse avant et décapité maintenant
il vient de découvrir le feu
on passe du cru au cuit
moi je suis sûr que d'ici quelques
millions d'années ils feront de très
jolies peintures rupestres
[Musique]